you will always be known as the man who
turned around IBM and just before the
break we were talking quite a bit about
passion you're passionate about a number
of other things education to start where
is your passion today well it's still
with education I mean 70 there's one
thing that's causing income inequality
in this country if there's one thing
that's holding back our economic growth
if it's one thing that I think is
contributing to the divisiveness in our
country it's that we're not educating
our young people the state of k-12
education in this country is truly
devastatingly bad I mean one in five
Americans reads below the fifth grade
level then realistically how does that
get changed realistically realist
idealist no no we know exactly what it
takes to change we need high standards
we need better teachers which means more
pay for the teachers more pay for the
better teachers less for the poor
teachers better prepared teachers by
getting rid of all these horrible edge
schools we need choice for parents we
need accountability for that we can get
that up how we're going to get there
we're going to get there with some very
courageous governors and mayor's because
the schools in this country are run by
the states and we also need to bring in
competition with charter schools I mean
one of the reasons we have the best
collegiate level school system in the
world is because we have competition
competition for students competition for
faculty we need to get these schools
focused on the right things and we got
to get the adults out of the way well no
I'm so glad you went there because i
have a small charity i work with in
public schools try to help and the thing
that struck me about this morning else
is nobody's thinking about the kids all
the adults all fighting with each other
whether it's the teachers or the
teachers unions or the administration or
the politicians how do you get that
align this is not like a CEO of IBM who
could say we're all going to march in
that direction and i can affect your pay
this is much more complicated how do you
get the adults to actually focus on the
kids I don't know because that is the
big problem David so let's take some
common core Common Core was created by
the states and it is absolutely
essential that we have standards for
what kids are to learn when they
graduate from high school it's that
simple what should kids know when they
graduate from high school math and
English language guess what we have
politicians in this country trying to
tear down common core you know why for
their own political advantage and
they're destroying the opportunity of
these kids so that they can appeal to
people but before we go we have to talk
medical research moment we talk about
politicians I think about NIH funding
and the fact that they have lost so much
fun it's turned to private groups or
institutions to help move things forward
you're you've obviously done a lot of
work with the Broad Institute where do
you stand right now okay so Stephanie
you stated it quite correctly i would
say that we are in the most important
scientific understanding scientific
discovery in the history of humankind
and there's no hyperbole there we're
starting to learn what makes life work
what makes life get extended what causes
diseases this is the most exciting side
why don't we vote to support that and to
actually put money toward question 70
the NIH which is the biggest supporter
of biological research in this country
its budget is down twenty-five percent
in real terms over the last ten years we
are not investing in this important
science and the broad is thank goodness
supported by incredible philanthropists
and is doing a lot of the heavy lifting
because it's hard we still don't
understand much molecular biology you
know we're promising people you know
will take a little bit of your blood and
all of a sudden will cure your cancer
well we're way ahead of ourselves Vice
President Biden was interviewed on 60
minutes last night and it was very
compelling when he talked about cancer
he said this could be like deciding
where to land a man on the moon if we
simply decided as a country we could
cure it do you think that's realistic I
think it's realistic if we put the
resources behind it there's no question
about it but you know we we now have
identified probably a hundred different
genes out of the 20,000 at our genome
that
are related to cancer we haven't got
them all there are many many more and we
don't know how they work together we but
we will figure it out we will figure out
what happens if we go after these
pharmaceutical companies and regulate
where they are pricing drugs and Big
Pharma says you know what we're going to
cut rd then what happens what could be
the impact because we rely on a lot of
these companies to do the work for us
well first of all I'm really not a fan
of regulating prices in any industry I
just don't think it works and but the
pharma companies are very important they
tend to work out at the far end of how
can we get clinical applications in two
patients what the bro does is it focuses
on the really hard underlying questions
of why to say we create 400 billion new
cells in our body every day 400 billion
every day 300 million die every minute
so what is that process that leads those
cells to die and to form and how do we
intervene in that process because that
is the process that creates the
mutations that cause disease a lot of
work left to do and and I'm delighted
that the Broads right at the center of
it